um Gino have you messaged  anybody in this cast what do you mean uh  have you like sent DMS or anything to  anybody that you have met through this  cast through this cast yes  ma'am I mean I've talked to the cast  themselves yeah um  but no but that's it nobody nobody that  has a connection with anybody in this  cast  no  okay so what about Benjamin's friend  Jessica  what about her  have you messaged her  uh uh no okay but there's not been any  communication between you and her at all  uh why is Sean asking you these  questions  okay here we go what happened I'm gonna  tell you something you know  the truth always prevails so confess  right now and whatever I have to hear  right now I wanna hear it from you not  from Sean not from bang not from anyone  that is there I want to hear it from you  why is Sean asking you these questions  [Music]  thank you  [Music]  foreign